so today's video is sponsored by
Brilliance but more on them later so
this summer is almost over the school
year is starting and with that we find
that we must set goals again for the new
year achieving our goals Can Be Imagined
as Plato did painting the picture of a
chariots here guiding two horses we are
the shared here with intellect and
reason guides us towards our goals but
we have to guide two horses we have our
left horse a spirited horse with courage
and bravery and we have a right horse
which is a positive as axes and desires
driving the horses will only work when
we are in harmony but how do we achieve
that so today I want to talk to you
about the Neuroscience behind behavioral
change and goal setting and I will give
you some tools tips and techniques as
steeped in Neuroscience such that you
may hopefully reach all the goals that
you want for the new school year so
let's dive straight into it so when we
think of setting goals we are
effectively trying to change our
behavior and all behavior Can Be
Imagined as on a square so if we think
of the two axis of the square on the one
side we have our motivation to do a
certain Behavior so we can be low
motivated to do something for example
cleaning or highly motivated for example
eating and on the other axis we have our
skill so what is our ability to achieve
this certain behavior and usually when
we look at this Square we want to be in
this upper corner right so we want to be
in novel but complex behavior that is
really motivating for us and when we
think of complex motivating behavior
that we want to do or learn it's usually
some type of skill we try to accumulate
so it can be for example learning a new
instrument or learning a language or it
can be that we want to do really well in
school so I first want you to ask
yourself a question when you look at
this Square so if you think of the Habit
you want to cultivate or the goal you
want to achieve is the reason you are
not achieving this goal cool because you
do not have the ability to achieve this
Coral or that you do not have the
motivation so in Neuroscience in this
paper down below they call the ability
to reach something the way to get there
and the motivation to do a certain goal
or have it the will so in this video I
will really dive into Neuroscience
techniques to optimize the way or your
skill levels to reach certain goals and
in another video I will really talk
about the Neuroscience behind motivation
so look forward to that so the way of
goal Pursuit is the set of cognitive
skills capacities and abilities
collectively known as executive function
so executive function is a combination
of many skills it's usually related to
attention working memory in a bittery
control and planning and collectively
these are known as executive functions
and when we think of executive functions
they play a huge role in goal setting
and achievement of certain behaviors
right because we usually have to inhibit
our access or our desires and we have to
really strive towards future planning so
all these higher cognitive functions
need to be super sharp for us to be able
to achieve certain goals so the question
you may have is how do I increase my
executive functions and are my executive
functions somehow limited so today I
will answer these questions and I will
also give you four tools steep the
Neuroscience that can hopefully help you
increase or utilize your executive
function to the best of your ability so
when you think of executive functions
there are usually three things that keep
in mind it's effortful it's done
consciously and it is usually for
achieving novel type of behaviors so in
general in Neuroscience executive
function has said to be controlled by
the prefrontal cortex although nowadays
in Neuroscience we think more of a
network type of structure when we think
of certain type of behaviors and how
they can be mapped back onto the brain
so the first thing to then consider is
is executive function somehow a limited
resource and the question if we look at
it from a neuroscience or a biological
perspective is probably no executive
function doesn't have some kind of
limited capacity as to how we can use it
our brain is kind of an endless resource
except for the sense of fatigue and of
course getting tired but mostly people
now think that the sense of fatigue is
more psychological and less to do with a
super specific biological substrate but
if our executive function somehow is not
a limited resource how can we optimize
for it to reach our goals better well I
will give you four tools that I've kind
of covered that are in neuroscience and
they're also in the papers down below so
if you want to learn a little bit more
about the Neuroscience behind it I
highly recommend reading the papers of
course so the first thing is that we
usually have two types of operating and
one is based on more habits more direct
goals operating and the other is more
based on planning so when you think of
your day it's good to separate it into
the executor and the planner and I think
the planner should be in my Regard in
the early morning hours because we are
usually less limited by fatigue and then
it's said that executive function should
be brought to bear on any and all
aspects of behavior change such as golf
setting that benefit from openness to
new ideas broadened attention and a wide
survey of possibilities so if you think
of this that you only want to use your
executive function or this really deep
cognitive reasoning when you are doing
your planning and you want to rely on it
less when you have to do habitual type
of behavior so to use this I would do a
I would look at to plan your day ahead
of time schedule a time in a week where
you will plan your hours and make a list
of short but achievable goals and this
is them related to decreasing the
decision fatigue such that when you are
in the executor mode you can just
execute on the plan that the planner
mode has made so when you look at your
day divide it up into execution and
planning and the second tip I want to
get is that we usually divide a lot of
our behaviors and goals into have to's
and want to's and what is kind of
interesting for this from a
psychological perspective is that we
have homework for example which is have
to's and we have watching TV or talking
to friends which are wantos but actually
the amount of cognitive effort these two
tasks require are quite similar it's
more our perspective on these tasks that
make them so tiring so if you can
somehow switch the narrative from
behaviors that are right at this moment
have to still want twos so for example
if you have to do homework think why you
chose this study or think what motivated
you to start doing this in the first
place and that usually allows you to
rewrite the narrative that you have set
for yourself for that certain type of
behavior the third thing I want to dive
into is in the paper they say our
cognitive bandwidth is precious and
operates most efficiently in mental
Solitude so this is kind of to say that
we want to carve out distraction free
time every day where we can really focus
on our goals so if you have a really big
goal try to find a place in your home or
a study place where you can really be in
the zone as they say and that you have
distraction free moments to really focus
on your work so one thing that you could
do which I always talk about is to break
up your work into smaller Pomodoro like
sessions and during those sessions to
read really not allow yourself to be
distracted by anything because this type
of distraction is super detrimental to
our ability to focus on the goals we
have set for ourselves and the fourth
thing of course is habits so we talked a
lot about executive function but when we
think of goal setting and goal striking
we don't only want to rely on our
executive function which is the planner
we also want to be the executor a large
part of our time and a huge thing that
can help with this is to cultivate
certain habits towards your goals so if
you have read the book tiny habits which
I highly recommend he talks a lot about
having a prompt and a prompt then
inspires a tiny behavior and then you
have an instant celebration afterwards
so for example the prompts could be that
every morning you drink your coffee and
after you drink your coffee you will
read one page of a book and the instant
celebration is just to have a little
cheer for yourself for example and that
way you can slow only cultivate the
habit of reading more and instead of
every day waking up and relying on your
executive function to think like oh what
do I have to do now how do I plan for
this Behavior what comes next you can
kind of fall back on your habits to
really allow you to reach your goal a
lot faster and not to rely on your
executive function only so I know that a
lot of you are working on habits and
working towards learning certain science
goals which is me too and that's why I
want to talk a little bit about today's
sponsor Brilliance so I have been using
brilliant to dive into some of the
topics that I love so one of the courses
they have is about Quantum Computing
which I think is super cool for such an
interactive and easy tool and another
course I'm personally diving into right
now is the fundamentals of computer
science because I never really learned
about the fundamentals and the way I do
it is that I allow myself to
procrastinate on science but only with
more science but the procrastination I
use has to be fun and kind of gamified
so that's why I really like to use
brilliant for any time I get bored with
my own work I kind of just go on
brilliant and learn something new or
interesting for the day to get started
for free visit brilliant.org lots of
Hasa or click the link in the
description and the first 200 of you
will get 20 of brilliant's annual
premium subscription so instead of being
bored on Twitter or YouTube just play
around with Brilliance so these were my
tips for today and if you have any tips
or tools or techniques for me I would
love to hear them so put them down in
the comments below and otherwise see you
next week bye